how to deal with self-doubt so I got a
great question for my youtube viewers
love you guys
andrew who wrote insane is got a young
friend Lee's got a young startup it's
not taking off for him he's starting to
question himself he's starting to wonder
you know do I have the entrepreneurial
Drive can I actually do this and he
wanted my advice on what to do next so
Andrew have two bits of advice to you
one it's totally normal and to remember
your why so the first point it's totally
normal
this is normal every entrepreneur goes
through this multiple times we like to
put our best foot forward we like people
to see only the positive side of us but
every entrepreneur at some point usually
multiple times thinks about quitting you
never hear about it nobody talks about
it you don't go to a networking event
and somebody comes up to you and says hi
I'm John yeah I don't know if I'm gonna
keep doing my business or not because
it's not taking off and I'm really
doubting myself right that never happens
but in reality everybody at some point
will be doubting themselves so
understand that it's normal and that's
totally okay which brings me to number
two remember your why you have to have a
strong enough why to get you through
this this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs fail they don't have a
strong enough why they jumped into the
business because maybe they thought it
would make them a lot of extra money and
they weren't prepared for the failures
and the Smashing of your self-worth
starting the business is one of the
hardest things you will ever do in your
life and you have to have a powerful
enough Y to get you through it something
way more powerful than just the money so
let me tell you about two times in my
life where I thought about quitting my
entrepreneurial dream the first was with
my first company where I was making $300
a month and wasn't able to survive and I
told my partner I quit and and you know
cried that night and the next day I woke
up and I went back to work with him and
what helped me through that was you know
I wanted to do something important and I
wanted to do something with that team
and I felt like I was putting up too
soon and and I would regret it that was
really my important why I loved what we
were doing I loved the people I was
working with and I felt like if I look
back in my life
I was 70 years old and I actually quit
there that I would regret it and I
wasn't making any money right I was I
was making $300 a month and could barely
survive and that's what got me through
that was what my important why was and
that that led us to be able to continue
to push on the second one is when I
started helping entrepreneurs I went to
do a presentation I was looking for a
new business model it sold my company I
was looking for a new thing to do with
my life and I was asked to do this
presentation at the YMCA
and we had done all this promotion of it
and only three people showed up for that
event and and it just killed me because
I put all of this time and effort and
value in and it just made me feel like
how am I ever gonna make a business out
of this how am I ever gonna be
successful when I can only get three
people to come to a free event but I did
that event I made the presentation and I
know that I touched those three people
who came out to see me
and when I walked away from that I knew
I had to continue to find a way to do it
I didn't know how I was gonna work out I
didn't know what the path was gonna be
but I knew that I loved it so much that
I had to find a way to continue doing
that and that was 12 13 years ago and
there's been so many ups and downs along
the way but my love for helping
entrepreneurs continues to burn bright
and makes you want to continue doing
this now it's taken the form of YouTube
videos I never would have thought that I
would be here doing this when I look
forward from where I was before but I
trusted that things would work out
because I was doing work that I loved
and that was my strong why to keep going
so you're going to be tested multiple
times in your career as an entrepreneur
and it's really going to come down to
how strong is that why and is it
powerful enough to keep you motivated to
keep going look at any entrepreneur and
look at their success story and look at
all the failures that they had to
overcome and not path the success most
people never make it because most people
quit and they give up too soon so find
your why make it powerful and believe in
your dream all the way believe for those
you watching I'd love to know what your
why is leave it in the comments below
and I'll be joining in the discussion
and if you like this video you want to
see more don't forget to subscribe to
the channel thank you so much for
watching
I'll see you soon I'm Calvin Moya I'm a
singer-songwriter and regular
personality I subscribe to Eva's
newsletter a few years ago it has really
helped me the newsletter is very
informative and inspiring and it has
helped me throughout my career so I
encourage you to don't give up you can
make it
subscribe to Evans newsletter today you
won't regret it
you